du Congrès des Mair puisquil s'est
achevé hier il a eu lieu toute la
semaine et c'estisabeth borne qui a
prononcé le discours de clôture avec
quelques annonces pour donner au maire
le pouvoir d'agir Jonathan duprz en
l'absence d'Emmanuel Macron au Congrès
des Maires le discours de la première
ministre était très attendu devant les
éil Elisabeth borne a annoncé plusieurs
mesures pour leur redonner dit-elle les
moyens d'agir une manière pour
l'exécutif de tendre la main au maire
très éprouvé par un enchaînement de
crise nous devons rendre l'action
publique plus simple plus lisible et
plus
efficace notre premier enjeu c'est de
permettre un dialogue renforcé et
continu entre l'État et vous principale
annonce de la première ministre
l'augmentation de 100 millions d'euros
de la dotation de l'État aux
collectivités une rallonge qui
s'ajoutera au 220 millions
supplémentaires inscrit dans le budget
en cours d'examen au Parlement aussi je
vous annonce que j'ai décidé d'augmenter
la DGF des communes de 100 millions
d'euros supplémentaire la hausse
atteindra donc 320 millions d'euros
l'année prochaine vous l'avez souhaité
nous le faisons en 2024 la DGF des
communes augmentera au même rythme que
l'inflation devant les maires ellisabeth
borne a aussi promis le maintien de
l'amortisseur du prix de l'électricité
un dispositif permettant aux
collectivités d'économiser 1 milliard
d'euros cette année si ces mesures de
soutien financier ont été saluées
l'Association des maires de France
réclame surtout un nouvel
décentralisation que l'État laisse aux
communes plus de liberté pour agir
imaginez madame la Première ministre
chabth tout ce que nous pourrions faire
si l'état nous faisait enfin confiance
nous proposons que la France sorte de
cette matrice
recentralisatrice ce que nous vous
proposons et ce que je vous propose ici
au nom des maires de France c'est dooser
la liberté en réponse à ces
inquiétudesisabeth Bor annoncé pour le
printempset de décentralisation sur le
logement de quoi donner aux élus locaux
de nouveaux leviers sur la maîtrise du
foncier ou encore sur l'encadrement des
meublés de tourisme et on va revenir sur
ce discours d'Élisabeth borne mais
Jean-Baptiste d'abord peut-être un mot
un peu plus général sur le bilan de ce
congrès quel bilan on peut en faire B le
bilan est globalement
positif me permettre l'expression dans
le sens où la moisson d'argent public
est quand même venue en clôture de de ce
congrès les maires ont eu gain de cause
sur un certain nombre de leur de leur
requêtes donc voilà on est toujours dans
un dans un jeu de rôle assez
traditionnel c'estàdire qu'on a
l'Association des maires de France qui
qui fait monter qui fait monter la
pression qui dénonce une hyper une hyper
centralisation et puis finalement on se
retrouve à la fin avec un résultat
michev Michou par par par définition
c'estàdire que l'état donne un peu les
maires auraient souhaité un peu plus
mais en ce qui est fascinant dans le
système français on l'a vu encore lors
de ce congrès c'est que les maires récl
une forme d'indépendance vis-à-vis de
l'État mais finalement c'est la première
ministre qui vient conclure les travaux
monsieur Lisnard dit est très heureux
que 16 ministres soient passés Porte de
Versailles donc on est quand même
toujours et encore dans dans le même
monde une forme de paradoxen je sais pas
c'est une forme de paradoxe j'allais
dire oui ce que vous dites c'està
direire que c'est un jeu un jeu
traditionnel que l'on que l'on rencontre
lors de tous les les salons et les
congrès des maires la idée c'est que en
fait la difficulté des mes c'est pas
seulement bien évidemment le problème
des ressources hein mais ça ça çaen est
une mais c'est pas la seul c'est que
d'abord le premier point c'est qu'ils
sont confrontés du fait que leur mandat
soit un mandat de proximité à quasiment
tous les problèmes de la société
française les problèmes sociaux les
problèmes économiques les problèmes de
sécurité et c'est eux qui j'allais dire
on sont les les réceptacle en première
ligne ce sont les élus de première ligne
les maires d'une certaine façon donc
déjà il y a cette difficulté qui est lié
quand même à une forme de dégradation
malgré tout de la société française donc
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
c'est la relation avec l'État et et et
et la complexité de notre système quand
même administratif le le gros problème
aussi il est lié si vous voulez un maire
n'a pas les mêmes problèmes en fonction
de la nature la nature de sa commune de
la taille de sa de sa commune la grande
difficulté elle est aussi dans la
ruralité on le voit bien un certain
nombre de mares ruraux dans des petites
communes aujourd'hui finalement n'ont
plus tellement de moyens d'agir parce
parce que le pouvoir est d'une certaine
manière ailleurs il est notamment au
niveau des intercommunalités ensuite
c'est vrai que quand même on a vécu
depuis un certain nombre d'années une
entreprise de recentralisation de de
remainmise de l'État sur j'allais dire
les les prérogatives des maires donc
tout ça crée un un malaise alors qui ait
des nouvelles positives en matière
j'allais dire de de de de ressources
budgétaires c'est évident que pour pour
les pour les élus et pour les maires
c'est un point c'est c'est un point
positif mais à mon avis c'est pas
suffisant pour quelque part apaiser leur
malaise Quentin oui et c'est vrai que
pendant 3 jours on a eu toutes ces
tables rondes à au congrès de la Porte
de Versailles où les maires ont pu faire
la liste très longue de leurs
revendications alors certes c'est aussi
un jeu avec l'exécutif on demande
beaucoup de choses on espère à la fin
avoir quelques annonces mais on voit que
il y a quand même un sentiment général
une morosité face à ces complexités de
normes face aux difficultés aussi avec
les agressions d'élu les émeutes de juin
dernier aussi cette complexité de la
relation avec le concitoyen de plus en
plus exigeant des problèmes qui sont
quasiment des problèmes de société que
les Maes ont à gérer et face à cela on a
des mesures très techniques des plans
avec des agences mentionnées et cetera
et on a une salle qui attend tellement
et qui est tellement face à une
complexité de morosité que ce discours
peut paraître petit bras pour des mères
qui pendant 3 jours ont évoqué tous ces
sujets en congrès ou oui Elisabeth bord
a dit l'État ne doit pas être une
machine froide et en attendance son
discour on a quand même parfois eu ce ce
sentiment là c'est-à-dire qu'elle a elle
a égrainé toute une série de de de
mesures technique mais elle a dit
elle-même qu'elle était élue je l'avais
oublié je je dois bien vous dire dans le
Calvados puisqu'elle était élue député
mais elle n'a pas cette cette fibre là
même si elle a été préfaite pendant un
court temps de sa sa carrière elle ne
parle quand même pas tout à fait la même
langue que les les petits élus les élus
ruraux je dis ça sans sans forme
péjorative
et effectivement il y avait quand même
une forme de dialogue de Sour de ce
point de vue là en revanche avec les
associations d'élu elle sait mettre de
l'huile dans les roulages elle a une une
approche un peu socialdémocrate d'une
certaine façon c'estàd qu' elle donne du
GR à moudre aux élus comme on pouvait
jadis en donner au au au syndicat et de
ce point de vuel ça ça fonctionne bien
c'est plutôt une femme de parole il y a
une forme de de contrat de confiance qui
est en train de se se créer avec les
élus locaux oui alors c'est vrai que si
vous voulez le processus de
technocratisation de la de la politique
a vraisemblablement éloigné les élus
locaux dans leur relation avec le le
pouvoir il est loin elle est loin à
l'époque où nous avions des présidents
de la République qui avaient été élus
locaux je pense à Jacques Chirac ou même
à François mitéran qui a quand même été
un grand décentralisateur il faut son il
faut sen souvenir et peut-être le plus
grand décentralisateur de la 5è
République HC Orsen il disait qu'on
devrait interdire au président de la
République de se présenter s'ils ont pas
été élus local avant j'iraai pas jusque
là je je pense pas que ça soit je veux
dire une une solution mais c'est vrai
que malgré tout c'est une expérience et
l'une des spécificités si vous voulez de
de de d'Emmanuel Macron et et et
finalement de son système politique
c'est que lui-même n'a pas été élu local
jamais il a un cursus qui n'est pas du
tout le cursus sonorom républicain que
l'on connaît c'est-à-dire celui où l'on
où l'on où l'on franchit toutes les
étapes d'élus local à conseiller général
comme on disait à l'époque conseiller
départemental députés responsable
politique national ce qu'avait fait
d'une certaine manière Jacques Chirac
même s'il avait un parcours quand même
il faut s'en souvenir de de de de de de
de de haut fonctionnaires euh et donc il
a vraisemblablement un un déficit
d'approche et c'est vrai que les
relations quand même avec le monde des
élus locaux depuis 2017 sont des
relations qui n'ont jamais été très
simples d'autant plus que c'est c'est
c'est c'est ça le le paradoxe il est là
c'est que Macron quand même avait vendu
plutôt lorsqu'il était candidat en 2017
il faut toujours revenir aux origines he
quand même c'est important plutôt un
discours qui était un discours assez
allant sur la décentralisation il avait
parlé du fameux pacte girondin et
manifestement quelque part est-ce que ce
sont sa est-ce que c'est sa jeunesse
chevénemtiste qui est revenu d'une
certaine manière dans ses réflexes ça ce
n'est pas un président de la République
qui est un un président de la République
décentralisateur pas du tout en
l'occurrence par contre ce qui est ce
qui est aussi quand même ce qu'il faut
noter c'est que chaque fois qu'il y a eu
les des grandes crises dans son mandat
je pense à la crise des gilets jaunes je
pense aussi à la crise sanitaire il y a
toujours eu quand même un retour à un
moment donné vers l'échelon local comme
si l'échelon local était considéré comme
l'échelon qui allait permettre d'amortir
la crise alors donc il y a ce paradoxe
je crois aujourd'hui dans le dans le
mandat macronien on va parler de la de
la décentralisation avant de parler de
la mission ver Quentin un mot puisque
Emmanuel Macron qui a reçu les ma
mercredi à l'Élysée il a promis une
décentralisation réelle et audacieuse
euh la décentralisation il en parle
depuis quasiment le premier mois de son
premier mandat de 2017 oui ça ça revient
comme une comme une antienne
effectivement à chaque crise on souvient
qu'au moment des des gilets jaunes il
promettaient un grand acte de
décentralisation bon là on on en est
simplement au stade de la Mission hein
qu'il a confié à Eric vert il faut
attendre les conclusions au mois de mai
les maires évidemment s'impatient on
voit pas exactement ce qui se ce qui se
dessine il fait un certain nombre de
constats sans doute juste à l'Élysée
mercredi dit notamment que les
départements B par exemple touchent
principalement les ce qu'on appelle les
les frais de notaire enfin les droits de
mutation à à titre onéreux alors qu'ils
ont des compétences sociales donc il y a
il y a un lien entre les les les
recettes et les et champ de compéten des
collectivités qui n'est pas du tout
lumineux pour euh pour pour pour le
contribuable donc est-ce qu' va
renverser la table euh c'est pas sûr
hein c'est-à-dire qu'on est quand même à
2 ans à 2 ans et demi de la fin du
mandat on parle de forme de structure
très très lourde on souvient que Nicolas
Sarkozi et François Hollande se sont
quand même en partie casser les dents
sur sur ces réformes là François land
voulait supprimer le département et on
sent que chez Emmanuel Macron c'est
encore le maillon faible quand même le
département à sesux justement ça c'est
vrai que cette mission Eric vert dont on
attend le rapport pour le mois de mai
elle vient brouiller le message de ce
que veut exactement le président de la
République les élus locaux eux ils
veulent faire le plus simple possible
qu'il y ait surtout pas de Big Bang TER
terorial sauf que lorsque vous voulez
simplifier les strates et revoir les
comp les compétences et qui fait quoi
parce que les Français ne savent plus
qui fait quoi vous allez forcément
devoir faire une forme de mini même Big
Bang territorial et ça les élus locaux
n'en veulent pas on voit que on est
toujours en train de corriger les
dernières lois de décentralisation du
quinena Hollande donc là on on sait pas
très bien ce qu'il veut faire il y a
cette ambition il y a cette feuille de
route avec des missions précises àt et
les illus locaux qui sont perdus dans
exactement ce que veut faire le chef de
c'est vrai que la question de la
simplification est essentielle parce que
on le voit bien d'abord au niveau des au
niveau des administré des électeurs et
des électrices qui
aujourd'hui pour eux la carte
administrative telle qu'elle est
dessinée est très peu lisible donc il va
falloir à un moment donné faire des
choix alors les élus locaux veulent
peut-être pas un Big Bang certes mais ça
sera difficile si vous voulez de ne pas
de passer à une étape supérieure de
décentral isation si au préalable on ne
simplifie pas c'est me semble-t-il une
des conditions absolument essentielles
et d'ailleurs il y a quelques années je
me souvient nous dans la revue politique
et parlementaire on avait consacré un un
dossier aux collectivités
locales on avait on avait fait réaliser
un sondage du du point de vue des maires
et notamment des mairres des petites
communes par rapport à
l'intercommunalité au phénomène de
l'intercommunalité ce que l'on pouvait
noter c'est que y compris chez les
maires des petites communes il y avait
un phénomène fortement rceptif par
rapport justement au processus
d'intercommunalité parce que d'abord il
ne s'y retrouvaiit pas d'abord il s'y
retrouvait pas parce qu'il sentaiit
qu'il perdent un certain nombre de
prérogatives qui leur échappai ça c'est
un premier point et deuxème point ils
trouvaient eux-mêmes les structures qui
sont les ntres aujourd'hui parfaitement
illisible donc il y aura quand même une
nécessité de ce point de vue-là et là
là-dessus Macron a raison le problème on
fait comment ensuite et on fait comment
et il faut qu'il le fasse en
construisant un consensus et un
compromis avec les élus c'est toute la
difficulté de l'exercice on va parler du
ner de la guerre la question financière
puisqueélisabeth borne ça fait partie de
ses annonces hier Quentin voilà c'est le
chiffre clé du discours d'hier 100
millions d'euros pour les communes en
2024 une rallonge pour la principale
dotation que touche les communes la DGF
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
avec ces 100 millions le gouvernement
dit aligner la hausse de cette DGF sur
l'inflation puisque le budget contenait
déjà une hausse de 220 millions
d'eurosian autre annonce elle concerne
les hausses des prix de l'énergie voilà
une
importante je propose d'écouter la
première ministre
hier le gouvernement continuera à aider
les collectivités face au coût de
l'énergie l'amortisseur du prix de
l'électricité sera maintenu en
2024 voilà ça représente une somme de 1
milliard d'euros que n'auront pas à
payer les communes c'est ce qu' expliqué
hier la première ministre écoutez au
micro de Public Sénat la réaction du
président de l'Association des Maires la
mesure la plus forte qui a été annoncée
par madame la Première ministre c'est
celle sur l'amortisseur énergétique al
il est vrai qu'on paye les AMS de la
politique énergétique du précédent
gouvernement et et dès de précédent
gouvernement d'ailleurs le
démantellement de la filière nucléaire
qui avait été annoncé bon maintenant il
y a rétropédalage ce qui fait que on est
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes donc il est normal que l'État
assume ses décisions mais c'est une
décision forte qu'elle a annoncé oui sur
que nous demandion depuis l'été dernier
voilà des annonces concrètes on l'entend
plutôt saluer par les maires avant une
réflexion de plus longue haleine lancé
également hier la refonte de la DGF de
son calcul même chose dans les prochains
mois sur d'autres dossiers qui ont été
ouvert le statut de l'élu ou encore la
décentralisation de la compétence
logement ça fait partie des annonces
qu'on a retenu d'hier Jean-Baptiste sur
le plan financier elle a répondu aux
attentes des maires oui elle a répondu
en partie au aux attentes des mares et
puis Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez dit
avait ouvert un peu la la voix à
l'Élysée mercredi en annonçant une
réforme de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement alors ça c'est un peu
comme le milf territorial c'est il y a
toujours des perdants et des gagnants
donc c'est une réforme à haut risque un
serpent de mer dont on parle depuis près
de 40 ans donc là il se lance vraiment
dans un dans un grand chantier il est
plutôt habile Emmanuel Macron puisqu'il
a confié ce chantier là il a transmis
d'une certaine façon la patate chose au
Comité des finances locales présidé par
André leniel qui n'est pas ses amis mais
qui va devoir quand même agir et qui qui
s'est montré hier plutôt favorable à une
réforme de de ce type là si j'ai bien
compris ouais sur le plan financier euh
les Mair se désolent voir s'énerv du
fait que il y a une rupture de lien
fiscal notamment depuis la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation Arnaud oui
clairement mais si vous voulez bon
l'annonce en tout cas qui a été faite
hier sur l'amortisseur énergétique de ce
point de vue- là une bonne nouvelle mais
je pense pas qu'elle résolve l'ensemble
des difficultés évidemment financières
des des communes en plus il y a un autre
problème si vous voulez un problème de
fond qui dépasse le stade des communes
c'est que aujourd'hui i on sait très
bien il y a des inégalités territoriales
il y a une concurrence presque entre
territoires et l'une des difficultés
quand même de la décentralisation c'est
que la décentralisation a accentué la
concurrence entre les territoires elle a
renforcé les inégalités entre
territoires donc ça c'est un vrai
problème et d'ailleurs on le voit toutes
les études l'ont l'ont démontré il y a
des territoires qui sont plus attractifs
historiquement que d'autres et qui s'en
sortent mieux que d'autres donc l'un des
vrais sujets à mon sens qui sera euh sur
la table dans les dans les dans les dans
les mois et dans les dans les années à
venir c'est que comment on arrive d'une
certaine façon à en effet décentralisé
mais en assurant la cohésion la cohésion
territoriale et la crise des gilets
jaunes que l'on a vécu il y a maintenant
près de 3 ans ou 4 ans 5 ans même
excusez-moi 5 ans oui on en a parlé la
semaine dernière ben démontre que c'est
un sujet qui est un sujet encore
extrêmement saillant ouais et sur le
malêtre des maères puisqu'on en a aussi
beaucoup parlé notamment dans dans ce
congrès Jean-Baptiste avec ce chiffre de
démission des élus locaux une
quarantaine par mois dit David Lisnard
est-ce que là la première ministre a
apporté des réponses elle a parlé
notamment d'une enveloppe pour les
indemnités des élus des communes rurales
enveloppe quand même assez minime hein
on parle de 15 millions on parle de de
15 millions d'euros il y a un plan qui
va être présenté dans les prochaines
semaines par la ministre délégué aux
Collectivités on sait que le Sénat va
sans doute déposer son propre son propre
texte donc il il y a une volonté de
prendre cette question là à bras de corp
mais quand même je les indemnités ça
reste quand même une bombe politique
potentielle c'est toujours difficile
d'augmenter les indemnités des élus
surtout à un moment où nos concitoyens
quand même tirent la langue avec un un
pouvoir d'achat amputé par par
l'inflation il y a une vraie affection
des Français pour pour leur mère ils ont
une vision parfois un peu tronqué c'est
un peu l'image épinale du du du du maire
du village du chef du village qui décide
quand même de plus grand ch chose hein
vous le vous le disiez enfin il célèbre
les mariages et il gère le cimetière
hein souvent le le maire dans dans les
petites communes non je suis pas dur
c'est ce que disent les maires c'est ce
que disent les maires eux-mêmes
il ils en souffrent effectivement il y a
une technocratisation très très
forte des des des collectivités locales
avec des intercommunaités parfois
gigantesques de 100 150 communes et dans
ces intercommunaités les élus n'ont plus
voix au chapitre c'est l'administration
qui souvent est demande de pouvoir
d'agir oui bien sûr
sur est-ce que du coup ça ça crée des
inquiétudes ou ça doit alerter en tout
cas sur la vivacité de la démocratie
locale aujourd'hui Arnaud
oui moi je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
aussi bien enracinée que le laisse
paraître un certain nombre de sondages
parce que il faut vraiment se méfier des
effet d'optique d'abord il y a quand
même un phénomène alors il faut pas
prendre évidemment en référence le vote
des dernières municipales qui s'est
j'allais dire produit dans un contexte
qui est le contexte de la crise
sanitaire mais il y a quand même malgré
tout là aussi on le regarde alors sauf
sauf dans les communes rurales une
démobilisation électorale qui touche ai
les élections locales ensuite on voit
que si vous voulez les les élus locaux
sont aujourd'hui extrêmement pris à
parti parce que si vous voulez la la
difficulté de maire c'est qu'il a une
double casquette un maire il est à la
fois le représentant de l'État et il est
aussi le représentant de ses administrés
il faut jamais l'oublier
administrativement et en tant que
représentant de l'État en effet il est
comme on dit de manière très tr àorté de
BAFF et on voit qu'il y a un problème
quand même de démocratie locale le
principal par exemple problème de
démocratie locale aujourd'hui c'est
l'intercommunalité si vous voulez à un
moment donné nous avons des EPCI qui ont
de plus en plus de prérogatives qui ont
de plus en plus de compétences mais qui
quand même ne sont pas élus au suffrage
universel direct donc ça aussi le mode
de désignation alors ils sont féchés
pour certains d'entre eux mais le mode
de désignation de ces élus qui
aujourd'hui disposent d'un C nombre de
prérogatives extrêmement importantes ben
ça aussi c'est une question qu'il faudra
se poser si on veut approfondir la
démocratie locale un mot de conclusion
jean-bapste oui ben la participation
chute effectivement à à chaque élection
alors ça a été plus fort plus fort la
dernière fois mais c'est quand même un
phénomène assez massif mes confrères du
du courrier des mères av interrogé il y
a quelques années les les Français on
leur a demandé quel était le nom de leur
mère et ben on s'aperçoit qu'il y en
avait que 50 % qui savaient le nom de de
leur mère donc il y a vraiment une
fracture de ce type là et je vous dis un
dernier mot aussi sur le phénomène qu'on
a constaté aux élections sénatoriales le
bous des ma il s'est exprimé aussi dans
les urnes dans des départements comme la
cmarne où il n'y a aucun maire Front
national enfin rassemblement national et
ben on a vu un sénateurl quandme
ou